mit applaus wurden die geflüchteten an
vielen orten damals empfangen
im september 2015 doch die frage wie wir
mit ihnen umgehen hat uns tief gespalten
das ist auch heute noch spürbar und
spiegelt sich in den nachrichten die ich
erhalten habe
wir haben genug für unser gutmenschentum
getan
es wird zeit dass es aufhört 2015 war
der anfang vom ende
die meisten die so schreiben wollten
nicht mit mir reden
einer aber schon er hat mich nach
düsseldorf oberbilk eingeladen doch auch
marco möchte seinen vollständigen namen
nicht nennen
er schrieb mir mit der flüchtlingskrise
geht unser land den bach runter was
meinen sie damit
meine meinung ist es sind sehr viele
wirklich hilfebedürftige eingewandert
denen man auch helfen muss die sich aber
denke ich auch so verhalten ja jemand
der hinfällt indem man auf hebt oder
senkt man die hand gibt der sagt danke
und die meisten gott zu tun ist auch
soja aber leider habe ich das gefühl
dass sehr viele kriminelle mit
eingewandert sind immer müssen viel
härter durchgreifen wenn leute schwere
straftaten begehen dass die abgeschoben
und das regelung gibt es ja auch bei uns
ja wird aber meiner meinung nach nicht
konsequent durch durchgesetzt das
problem bei den abschiebungen ist ja
auch das ist ja bekannt dass oftmals die
dokumente dann nicht da sind dann erst
beispielsweise oder dass die länder aus
dem die menschen kommen sie nicht zurück
wollen ja was soll die deutsche politik
da machen das war habe ich höre ich auch
immer wieder nach da muss man dann muss
man das irgendwie geht kriegt jede
zweite abschiebung scheitert die zahl
der menschen die ohne aufenthaltsrecht
in deutschland leben wächst stetig viele
nicht nur marco finden hier versagt der
staat
seit acht jahren wohnt marco hier in
oberburg einem stadtteil von düsseldorf
der stark migrantische geprägt ist in
den letzten jahren war oberbillig in
verruf geraten vor allem als rückzugsort
für straftäter die polizei verstärkte
daraufhin ihre präsenz und sagte uns die
lage sei inzwischen im griff
marco sieht das anders dieses gefühl was
sie haben dass die kriminalität
gestiegen ist das haben ja viele auch
einige die uns geschrieben habe nur die
statistiken geben das ja nicht her also
die kriminalitätsrate ist ja nicht
gestiegen manche delikte sind leicht
gestiegen aber insgesamt haben wir da
jetzt was die zahlen angeht kein großes
problem mehr
warum glauben sie ist das so dass ihr
gefühl so viel anders ist als die zahlen
ich weiß nicht ob die statistiken alle
so richtig sind ich bezweifle dass
teilweise ich sehe hier ist wahnsinnig
in die zweite oder wenn ich gucke ich
informiere mich ja auch ich gebe dann
meistens wenn die steuerung was sie
zwischen der u bahn schläger oder oder
hier am frau begreift oder
vergewaltigung oder wirklich krieg auch
somit wenn ich das in baden für die
mannschaft die sich benehmen und frauen
auch beleidige man froh ist auch ständig
schon an gemacht wurde
die sagen aber selbst das ist eine
kleine gruppe richtig verstehe es ist
nicht alles aber ist es nicht so zu
sagen bei jeder gruppe von menschen dass
ein bestimmter anteil ein kleiner anteil
eben sich nicht an die regeln hält ja
das ist richtig aber ich finde man muss
auch in deutschland das recht habe wenn
jemand terminal straftaten begeht dass
man sagt so pass auf jetzt genug wenn
wir ein anderes land gehen
da müssen wir uns auch anpassen was
meinen sie genau mit anpassen anpassen
dass die deutsch lernen auch dass wir
uns verstehen dass die unsere kultur
akzeptieren unsere gesetze akzeptieren
diese drei grundsätze haben sie nicht
das gefühl dass die große mehrheit das
auch so sieht
er hat ja also viel fehle integrieren
sich natürlich und viele machen das
natürlich auch gott sei dank aber meiner
meinung nach sind viele
dies nicht tun wo man das gefühl hat die
hamburger fans sind die wollen auch nur
unter sich zu bleiben
wie sehen das die anderen menschen die
hier in oberbilk leben
mehr als 56 prozent von ihnen haben
einen migrationshintergrund
wer zu viele flüchtlinge reingelassen
spiel selber ausländer aber das beste
war was ist was meinen sie mit zu viel
zu viel
was ist das problem damit ja ich habe
selber kein problem damit aber
irgendwann ist jeder deutsche isst nicht
nur zu holen glaubt ihr in oberberg die
integration bleiben die menschen unter
sich oder gibt es auch mögliche
integration auch mit deutschen sehen sie
ja selber sehen sie hier irgendwo dort
schon wieder ausländer sitzen kaffee
trinken unterhalten gucken sie mal sehen
sie wollen also gibt es keinen austausch
das nicht an bord haben sie ja schon
sie sehen ja silber allein 2015 kamen
knapp 900.000 flüchtlinge insgesamt
leben aktuell 1,8 millionen
schutzsuchende in deutschland
einige von ihnen haben mir direkt
geschrieben kartoffel seiner hat ist
mittlerweile lifestyle eine ernste
nachricht kam aus eberswalde in
brandenburg
bin aus syrien seit vier jahren hier
aber dieses jahr das abitur geschafft
und arbeite nebenbei
[Musik]
trotzdem wurde ich schon zweimal
angegriffen
nur wie paares hat sie mir geschrieben
hallo mein name ist morgen mein name ist
jochen wird kommen mein haus 235
quadratmeter vom jobcenter bezahlt
worden sie war seit zwei jahren hier
fühlen sich wohl in der wohnung ja das
ist ein kleiner zwar noch aber ist für
mich ist reicht und da haben sie fotos
von ihrer familie
das ist hier meine mutter meine große
rote und das ist ein freund von mir sie
ist wie meine große schwester und das
sind da oben ist auch meine
klassenkameraden aus so ihn aus serien
wie sehr vermissen sie ihre familie die
noch in syrien ist sehr sehr viel
also man hat immer heimweh aber es gibt
kein anderes werk einen anderen
möglichkeiten
sie kam mit 16 als unbegleiteter
minderjähriger flüchtlinge nach drei
monaten ging er in die schule ganz ohne
deutsch zu sprechen
einen deutschkurs durfte er noch nicht
machen weil sein asylantrag noch nicht
bearbeitet war
so ging es viel heute genießt er den
sogenannten subsidiären schutz der alle
zwei jahre erneuert werden muss
einen familiennachzug ist damit
ausdrücklich nicht möglich fühlen sie
sich hier in deutschland willkommen
fühlen sie sich zu hause ja also ja und
nein
gleichzeitig ich fühle mich wirklich
mehr zu hause als jetzt wenn ich sie
jetzt nach so jan wiederkommen weil ich
habe es vorher freunde bekannte leute
die mich unterstützt haben aber
gleichzeitig will ich mich nicht zu
hause bin ich halt von rassisten oder
wenn ich an die medien sehr die bieten
die kommentare kommen wie kommen hierher
und nehmen unsere steuergeld und wir
haben keine andere möglichkeit sie haben
mir geschrieben dass sie zweimal auch
angegriffen worden sind also das ist nur
körperlich aber was sprachlich oder
beschimpft oder usw
das ist uns ja war fragen fragen sie
irgendeine frau die kopf trägt bringt
man sie angegriffen worden
wie will man sie beschimpft wurde es gab
ja die kölner silvesternacht die
vorfälle dort es gab jetzt die krawalle
in stuttgart und frankfurt was denken
sie wenn sie so was sehen also es ist
sehr schlimm also dass mir leid vor dem
mädchen die da waren die dass das wenn
der stimmen und sage ich nur dass nicht
alle so sind aber gibt es einige ja
schon aber dass es für allgemein hat wo
das alle sind so ist es wohl schätze
nicht wenn irgendeiner seiner flüchtiger
irgendwas macht dann fühlen wir uns ja
jetzt werden wir ihn alle in einen topf
geworfen und die sind alle so ihr seid
alle scheiße das zu sagen ihr habt das
so gemacht er habe das getan
aber wenn sie sich da als geflüchtete
unter besonderer beobachtung auch ja
alles was ich mache machen meistens
zählt ich habe angst dass ich auch etwas
falsches machen und dann wurde es halt
auch organisiert die fehler die ich
mache ist jetzt vielleicht mehr dabei
beim gedanken der anderen
navis traum irgendwann einmal medizin zu
studieren
aber noch weiß er nicht ob er überhaupt
dauerhaft in deutschland bleiben darf
integration geht nicht ohne sprache wer
dauerhaft hier in deutschland leben
möchte muss deshalb einen
integrationskurs belegen der beinhaltet
600 stunden sprachunterricht doch zur
wahrheit gehört auch die hälfte der
geflüchteten besteht die
abschlussprüfung nicht jeder zweite
spricht also salopp gesagt nicht gut
genug deutsch
außerdem steigt die zahl der
analphabeten unter den geflüchteten und
manchmal gibt es noch ganz andere
probleme
aus nord dorf in schleswig-holstein
bekam ich eine lange mail
[Musik]
im september 2014 gar nicht deutsche
geflüchtete zu unterrichten
ich war hoch motiviert und habe das gute
in allem gesehen
schnell wurde ich allerdings von der
realität eingeholt
susanne rotenburg hat mich eingeladen
hier in der volkshochschule hat sie 2014
begonnen geflüchtete in deutsch zu
unterrichten
sie haben geschrieben dass sie gute und
schlechte erfahrungen gemacht seiner
fangmann mit den booten an mit den guten
ja also ich habe teilweise wirklich hoch
motivierte flüchtlinge erlebt die jetzt
nach fünf jahren nach sechs jahren einen
gesellenbrief in der tasche da stellen
finde ich natürlich total klasse und das
motiviert mich dann das war ein langer
weg und die schlechten erlebnisse die
überwiegen in teilen ja also die die gut
hier ankommen
da denke ich immer das sind die die
wirklich unterstützt worden sind und die
auch wollen was waren das für schlechte
erfahrungen die sie gemacht haben
das fängt an mit leute die zum kurs
verpflichtet werden die dann nicht zur
schule kommen dann sind aber auch sachen
wie wenn jemand dauerhaft zu spät zum
kurs kommt dann tragen wir das 1
und dann kam jemand und sagte dann warum
trägst du dass ein und ich krieg an
meinem job center und da fühlt man sich
schon so ein bisschen bedroht ja das
frauenbild ist natürlich auch ein ganz
anderes teilweise werden wir als
lehrerin auch nicht nicht wirklich für
voll genommen sag ich mal oder die
denken wir können machen was sie möchten
nicht alle also immer einzelne aber das
macht natürlich auch ein bild wie sieht
dieses bild für sie aus ich gucke mir
mal die einzelnen personen an und ich
sage es gibt immer solche und solche
es gibt nie die syrer sind alle gut oder
die syrer sind alle schlecht aber um uns
mein gefühl zu geben für die relation
war dass einer von zwanzig war es einer
von 30 einer von zehn
ich würde sagen einer von zehn ungefähr
findet das viel
das finde ich schon fehlen ja ist das
wirklich viel oder erwarten sie von
geflüchteten dass sie sich erst recht
reinhängen weil sie hier aufgenommen
wurden
ich erwarte schon dass wenn jemand gut
wenn jemand vom krieg flüchtet und nicht
kann also ich will keinen zu irgendwas
verdonnern wenn jemand hierher kommt
schwer traumatisiert ist dann muss er
natürlich erstmal mit sich klar kommen
aber wenn ich hierher als
wirtschaftsflüchtling komme dann erwarte
ich was anderes
dann erwarte ich dass ich mich
einbringen müssen wir mehr darüber
ich glaube das wird uns gut tun können
wir mittlerweile sachlich darüber reden
ich glaube nicht
2018 entschloss sich susanne rotenburg
keine deutschkurse mehr zu geben
für einige geflüchtete setzt sie sich
aber weiterhin ein
der fußballplatz ja
zwei von ihnen treffe ich hier beim tsv
genutzt
selbst am abend sagt man noch neun oder
zehn jahren ich finde wieder freut mich
sehr
bilal als super war 20 sein bruder
mohammed 21 als sie gemeinsam aus syrien
flogen im januar 2015 kamen sie in den
integrationskurs von susanne rotenburg
sie lernten sehr schnell halfen bald als
dolmetscher aus umgekehrt unterstützte
rotenburg die beiden immer wieder bei
behördengängen und der suche nach einem
ausbildungsplatz
die begleitung der beiden also der
einsatz für die beiden haben sie ja
ehrenamtlich erbracht ja ohne dass das
irgendjemand war ist wie wichtig es
diese begleitung von ehrenamtlichen
ich würde sagen das ist sehr wichtig
weil es einfach es gibt sachen die
können die nicht wissen und die kann
auch keinen kurs beibringen man muss
immer auf die individuellen personen
gucken und auf die individuellen
umstände um genau dafür die passende
lösung zu finden und das geht nicht
staatlich glaube ich nicht was wäre wenn
es ehrenamtliche sie nicht geben würde
die diese hilfe anbieten ich glaube dann
hätten wir deutlich mehr probleme
deutlich mehr probleme
viele würden dann auch untergehen
doch es wird zunehmend schwieriger
menschen zu finden die sich ehrenamtlich
um geflüchtete kümmern
bilal hat inzwischen eine ausbildung zum
zahntechniker abgeschlossen mohammad
arbeitet in einem malerbetrieb seit sich
in deutschland sind seit den in den
letzten vier fünf jahren was war aus
ihrer sicht gut was man nicht so gut was
war gut dass wir versucht mit leute zu
kontaktieren das wird die sprache lernen
kennen und auch den geldwert und wir
sind in neuer kultur gekommen und werden
muss denn diese kultur auch lernen damit
wir die sind zu sagen die sind eis
brechen zwischen die heimlichen und die
zuwanderer ja so was nicht gut ist dass
die leute egal ob ich jetzt
abgeschlossene ausbildung gemacht oder
sie wissen nicht was was bin ich
sie guckt und einfach dunkle haare
dunkle haut der ist ausländer und so und
sie werden alles in meinem kopf geht es
ihnen auch so
ganz ehrlich gesagt ich würde mich zu
hause sie fühlt sich nicht zu hause
ein anderer kultur an das land was ist
das größte problem am anfang an war die
sprache mittlerweile sprechen sie ja
super deutsch wenn man hier bleiben will
oder wenn muss man was machen sondern
wir schaffen das dieser satz hat uns vor
fünf jahren gespalten was ist nun das
fazit dieser reise haben wir es
geschafft
klares jein wir haben es dort geschafft
wo ehrenamtliche helfen wo arbeitgeber
das potenzial erkennen wo geflüchtete
sich integrieren wollen eine hand
klatscht nicht ein schönes bild
doch nicht bei allen wird die
integration klappen auch das ist klar
manche können nicht manche wollen nicht
unter ihnen leiden auch die anderen
geflüchteten weil sie sich in einen topf
geworfen führen was wir definitiv noch
nicht geschafft haben offen über die
probleme der integration zu reden so
dass es wirklich um die sache geht und
nicht um den ideologischen standpunkten
wir müssen raus aus den gräben rein ins
gespräch nur dann können wir es als
gesellschaft auf dauer schaffen